Hi everyone,
my name is Dr.
Matthew Heller and I
will be presenting
lecture number 112
for you all.
I am excited to
be giving my first
lecture to the
NYTCOM class of 2028.
I am a graduate of NYTCOM, back
in the day we did
call it NICOM,
but now we call it NYTCOM.
So I'm a graduate and
I went on to do my
family medicine residency
at Goethe Samaritan
Hospital in West Islip,
New York, and I did my
sports medicine fellowship
down in Campbell
University School of
Osteopathic Medicine.
So during my time down
at Campbell, I got to be
the team doc, the team
physician for the athletic
program. They had a
Division I athletic program,
and then from Campbell,
I made my transition back
up to New York, where I
became the team physician
for the NYT Athletics.
So back in the day, and
when I say back in the
day, about five years ago,
we had a NYC athletic
program. We had basketball,
lacrosse, soccer.
We had a whole athletic
program, but unfortunately
with COVID, it just never
came back up after the COVID.
So I still stay active
in the community,
covering a lot of events,
right? I cover a lot of
pro wrestling, kickboxing,
MMA. I do a lot
of football games for
the local high schools.
I do bring the
students with me.
So if you guys
have any questions
at all, make sure
you let me know.
My email address is right over
here, amheller at nyt.edu.
So please email me if
you have any questions,
comments, suggestions,
concerns, any
ideas that I can
make the lecture more
entertaining. I try to
make it entertaining.
We'll see how you guys feel
in the next 58 to 59 minutes.
We'll see how you guys
feel after the lecture,
and if you have any
ideas, let me know.
And also, if you
just want to say hi,
feel free to send
me an email too.
No problem there.
Over here, not too
much of a Twitter or X,
but I know we don't go
by this logo anymore, so
we'll X that out. And
we have X, right? So,
and by the way, if
anybody knows the name of
the bird, that used to
be the Twitter logo.
Yes, you're in the front.
No, that is not correct.
So the Twitter bird is
actually named after, it's
named Larry the Bird, right?
Larry the Bird, right?
So if you take out the
word the in between Larry
the Bird, and you're going
to get Larry Bird, right?
and that was the name of
the logo during the time
that it was in existence.
So we will move on to
the learning objectives.
What we're going
to do today, we're
going to talk about
the bony and short
tissue injuries of
the lower extremities.
You all have the upper
extremities. It was a great
lecture, I watched it
three or four times
already, given by Noah, one
of your academic scholars.
So an amazing job. Very,
very high yield stuff.
Know it for the upcoming
exams. Know it for
the old exams you're going
to have in the future.
We're going to talk
about complication. We're
going to talk about
complication because
we want to be able to
prevent complications.
So in order to prevent
complications, and not
only to prevent, but to
be aware of complications.
Because if you're not
aware of potential
complications, then it
might be something that
you get overlooked.
work, and patient may
become symptomatic
due to a complication.
We're going to talk
about the management
options in the lower
extremity injuries.
We're going to recognize
bone and soft tissue injuries
to the lower extremities.
We're going to identify
what's urgent, what's
emergent, and any other
conditions and how to
evaluate and treat, and how to
interpret and apply clinical
signs and symptoms of lower
extremity processes in the
differential diagnosis.
So a lot of the clinical
exam we're going
to do in our DPR
lecture. So I do have a
few more lectures for
you all coming up.
It's basically DPR and
how to do a physical
exam for the muscular
skeletal system.
I think I do a few of
the lectures and then we
have another professor
doing a few of the others.
So who are we?
So, hello down in Jonesville,
right, so we don't
forget about you, we
appreciate you, right, so
hello to the Red World,
and up here is the New York
Tech in New York,
Jonesville is the Red World.
So, some of my lectures,
I might start off
with something totally
off topic, that's just
to get me warmed up for
the lecture, get you
all warmed up for the
lecture. All right,
so I'm going to begin
with a quick pop quiz.
So my pop quiz for
you all is going
to be if you all can
name this runner.
So I know some people
are thinking that this
might be me, but
honestly, this is not me.
And this is a picture
of me and my running.
So a little bit
different style,
definitely a lot slower
than the other guy.
But this is me, and this is
when we had the athletics.
I actually ran for New York
Tech during my undergrad.
I was a BSDO, so shout-out
to all the BSDOs out there.
So basically, I came
into med school in my
fourth year out of high
school, basically. So I
did three years of running
during my undergrad.
But my question, more
specifically for you all,
is to be able to name
who is this guy. And also
by this picture, you
can tell that this is
definitely not made. This
picture was taken in 1954.
So 1954,
a young man by the name
of Roger Bannister did
something that everybody
thought was impossible.
So I bring this up
because he was able to do
something that was totally
impossible at the time and
that was thought at the
time so this was thought to
be impossible and what
he was able to do was he
was able to run one mile
in under four minutes right
that's incredible right
so running a mile on the
four minutes right and
he did this while he was
in medical school imagine
that so he was a medical
student in london at saint
mary's hospital and he
went on to do what everybody
said was impossible.
So Roger Bannister
became that first person
to break the four
-minute mile, and then
once he did it, right,
everybody realized it
was no longer, it was
no longer impossible,
but it was possible.
And he didn't just do it
because he was just very
good. He did it because he
was very persistent and very
diligent in his work,
right? So everybody is going
to have the up and down
right and and the people that
do the best are the people
who are able to get up
stronger after being down
he overcame failures two
years prior um he didn't even
match he didn't even medal
at the olympics right so
in the 1952 olympic he
ran in the 1500 meters and
1500 meters a little bit
shorter than a mile he
placed uh fifth place uh not
fifth uh fourth place and
so he didn't get a medal but
he went right back to
training and on race the sixth
1954 on a day where it
wasn't the ideal condition
to even break any kind of
record um he went on to do
uh to do exactly what he
wanted to do and that was
to run the first be the
first person to run a mile in
under four minutes right
so uh definitely you all
have the ability to do the
impossible just because
something seemed like it's
impossible, you work hard,
you can take out the IM and
you can make it possible.
So once you stop
believing something is
impossible, it becomes
possible. So he
ended up breaking the
4 minute mark and then
just after that, 46
days later, another
person who goes by the name
of John Landy, he ended
up beating his time and he
broke the uh the mile with
a four minute with a 358
mile time okay so and um yes
so we will move on to uh
talking about the hip all
right so we're talking about
lower extremities so we're
going to work our way at
the hip and kind of work
our way down all right so
we're going to talk a little
bit about the anatomy we're
going to talk about sports
injuries uh hip dislocation
right um hip fractures,
hip and knee degeneration,
right, replacement,
because we're going to be
in a field where we're going
to be taking care of patients
of all ages, right, and
we all know that as we get
older, right, bone degenerates,
um, cartilage degenerates,
right, bone form
calcification, and it doesn't
work as smoothly as it
normally would when we are
younger, right, and we call
that arthritis, and we're
going to have a lot of patients
that's going to come in
with these type of pain.
So talking about the
anatomy, right, so we have a
hip joint, right, so you have
a hip joint, and basically
with a hip joint, right,
it's a ball and socket
joint, right, and I think
that's the key thing to
remember, ball and socket,
right, so you can't have
a ball and socket joint
unless you have a ball and
you have a socket, right,
so the socket is going to
be the acetabulum, right,
along with the, along with
the labrum, and the ball
is going to be the femoral
head right so the socket
again is formed by the
acetabulum which is part of
the the pelvic bone uh so
you're going to have a
cartilage you're going to have
extra cartilage that kind
of goes over the surface
right and um it's going
to create basically what
this whole function does
this whole joint is that it
wants to create a very low
friction area right you
have a low friction you
have a very smooth area the
bones move nice and easy
right so that when you're
running, right, you're
not getting bone on bone,
right, you're getting a
nice smooth movement, right,
it's going to decrease
the chance of getting any
pain, right, and then
again we have the labrum,
right, so looking at this,
right, so three o'clock is
always going to be
anterior, right, so this is
the clock, this is what the
ortho will do when they're
going for surgery, and
this is how they're going
to adjust the anatomy
they're going through. And
then when we talk about
hip dislocation, right,
basically what we're
talking about is the
femoral head, which
belongs to be right here.
It's going to come out
and it's going to go up
into the iliac fascia,
right? And that's not
a good thing. I've got a
hip dislocation because
you want to make sure
that you get the hip
joint in place. And
we're going to talk a lot
more about hip dislocations
in a little bit.
So again, we have the
labrum, right? The labrum is
It's a cartilage structure,
more like a fibro
-cartilage structure that
attaches to the acetabular
rim. It's responsible,
again, for a lot of things,
basically to keep the
hip joint healthy and to
provide stability through
intra-articular pressure.
It's going to provide
stability of the hip joint.
And then over here, we
mentioned the ball, the ball
goes into the socket. we have
the femoral head over here,
and then we have the femoral
neck, and then we have
the rest of the femur, right,
and we're going to talk
a lot about the different
types of fractures along the
femur, right, and we
will talk about how
different types of
fractures, different areas of
femur are going to have
different management.
So again, pictures, right,
we have a lot of pictures,
So basically, I'm going to
reiterate one more time,
we have the ball and sockets
joint with the femoral
head, and the acetabulum,
and then the labrum is
that fibrocartilus that
comes along the side as well.
So very important to
know that we need to make
sure that the bone gets
good blood supply. right?
It's going to have
blood supply, and when
you have a disruption to
the blood supply, it's
not a good thing
because now you're going
to get something called
avascular necrosis,
right, which basically
means death to the caudalus.
So the main artery that
we're going to have, right,
we have the circumflex femoral
arteries, right, mainly
it's going to be the
medial circumflex artery,
right, that we worry about
when we get a hip dislocation,
right? So you have medial
circumflex artery that
we're concerned about um
when that becomes disrupt
because if that becomes
disrupt you get avascular
necrosis and that is not a
good thing because that's
going to leave some more
complications complications
as time goes on and so
again the main artery is the
medial circumflex femoral
artery very very high yield
uh just make sure you know
it now know it forever
and um and within the capsule
right there's a capsule
that goes up here right
within the capsule, you're
also going to have the
retinocular arteries as well.
One of the things we worry
about in a posterior hip
dislocation, right, is
impingence on a nerve,
right. So what nerves in the
posterior pelvic is going
to be these sciatic
nerves. So I put this down
here, you see how big this
nerve is, right. So when
we, this femoral head is
coming out posteriorly,
it's going to impinge on
a nerve, it's going to
create a lot of pain, it's
going to create potentially
complications.
We're going to talk about
some sports medicine
injuries, right? So this is
a great check that I like
on sports medicine, right?
There's a lot of great
sports medicine checks
that are out there, right?
We're going to talk
about proximal hamstring
injuries because those
that may have been runners,
right? Especially when you all
were a little younger, right?
As you guys were growing,
right? So basically what's
happening is the bone is
growing faster and the
muscles right and now the
muscles are becoming tight
and now you're forcing
a sudden stress on the
musculotendinous junction
a very big word but if you
notice that if you in
medicine if you break down a
lot of big words right it
kind of makes sense right
it kind of break down
into two different words
right so here we have the
muscles and the tendon
right so you know muscles
attaches the tendon tendon
attaches to bone right so
when the muscles contract
it pulls on the tendon
pools on the bone, and that
allows for any kind of
movement within the body.
When there's a very
severe hamstring
injury, you're going
to have a complete
avulsion that may
occur at the issue.
What is an avulsion,
it's basically
a bone fracture that occurs
when a ligament or a
tendon, most commonly a
tendon, in this case
because of the hamstring,
so when a tendon is
torn, it might pull
a piece of the bone
to come with it.
Sudden pain, right, some
of you may have had it
in the past, right,
you're going to know it's
there, in the posterior
thigh, up to the ischium.
Some might feel some numbness
and tingling in
the area, right,
corresponding to the
sciatic nerve, and
the way we treat
it, you're going to
see the term rice
over and over again,
right, so basically, I
know it was mentioned
so many times in the
last lecture, it's
rest, ice, compression,
and elevation,
right? I just threw a blank
there. I do apologize.
So that's ice, compression,
and elevation, right?
And then when you have a
complete abortion injury,
right, sometimes a surgeon
may look at it, and depending
on how much it's
retracted, right, you might
need to go and get some
early surgical intervention,
right? The longer you
wait, the more it's going
to retract, and then
it's going to be harder
to put it back in or
put it back in place.
And then we have the rexous
femoris strain or the hip
flexor strain. This is more
common than the complete
avulsion, so the rexous
femoris is the most common
strain in the quadriceps.
So you have the quadriceps,
again quad means four,
four major muscles, and you
have the hip flexor. And
remember the rexous femoris
attaches to the A-I-I-S,
and basically the mechanism
is going to be when you
go to kick a ball, whether
it's a football or a soccer
ball, And you might have
done this before, you go
to kick the ball, and you
go to kick as hard as you
can, and you end up *******
the ground, something like
that, or your foot hit
another player in the middle
of the ******* motion,
that's going to cause
a complete stop of
that ******* motion,
and that's going to
create a sudden change
in the hip flexor.
Acute pain in the midline
of the anterior thigh, it's
going to be acute pain,
and guess what? Treatment
is going to be right in
rehab, and if there's any
proximal rupture, then
you've got to make a decision
whether you're going to
do surgery or non-surgery,
and it depends on the
patient, depending on their
activity level, right? Are
they college athletes, or
are they somebody that's
more of a weekend warrior and
what they're looking to
get out of further rehab.
So FAI, right? FAI, right?
That saves you from saying
the big word, right? Femoral
acetabular impingement,
right? So this is something
that we talk about internal
hip, right? So internal
hip pain, right? This
basically comes, we talked
about before, we have the
ball, the femoral head,
and the acetabulum, which
is the socket, right? And
so when the ball on the
socket is not smooth, right,
when they're motioning, when
they're moving together,
right, maybe they're impinging
on each other, right,
this is going to create
pain, and this is going
to create discomfort, right.
So there's two major types,
and then the third type
is basically a combination
of the two major types,
right. So the cam is going
to be the femoral head
that is not round, and it's
going to have a little bit
of a bump. I'm going to
show you on the next slide
what I mean by that, right.
And then you have the
pincer, right, where the
acetabular has an extra bone
growth that extends beyond
the normal rim of the
acetabulum, right, and it's
going to impinge on the
femoral head and the labrum.
Symptoms, limited
range of motion,
especially in the
groin and the hip,
especially with flexing
and internal rotations,
right. So flexing and internal
rotation, that might ring
a bell. If not, it will,
because I have your DPR
lecture coming up. Make
sure you're there. and we're
going to talk about a test
called Fadiar's chest,
right? So Fadiar's
chest, F-A-D-I-R, right,
basically when you put
the hip in flexion,
adduction, and internal
rotation, right? So
when they have pain,
you're going to be
thinking, okay, maybe
they have FAI potentially.
Non-surgical, rest, ice,
compressing,
elevation, physical
therapy, activity modification,
and then there's some
surgical procedures, right,
Whether you go on to the
acetabula, you do some
trimming of the acetabulum,
of the extra growth,
of the bone growth, you
might need to do a labor
repair. If you can't do
a labor repair, then you
do a labor reconstruction
or osteochondroplasty.
And basically, like
I mentioned before,
I'm going to show you the
picture on the other slide.
So osteochondroplasty is
basically, it's another
surgical procedure that's
used, right, and more
specifically of the cam
type, right? So when you have
that ball, right, the femoral
head that has that extra
bump, right, what you're
going to do is you're
basically going to cut down
the entire side of the femoral
head, right, just to
make it so that it's not
going to create a lot of
friction when you're moving.
All right, so FAI, picture
speaks a thousand words
sometimes, and I'm going
to show you that the
pincer over here from the
AXA tabular is impinging
on this demo head, that's
going to create pain.
All right, let me talk
about the cam, and that's
going to create pain, that
little bump, right? Every
time you move, you're
moving your hip. All right,
so I mentioned before, you
get the cam bump, one thing
that they do is they kind
of come and they kind
of kind of shave it down
so you don't have all that
all that friction when you
are moving right we look
at the picture this is before
I kind of overdrew on the
slide it's not overdrew you
could probably still see
the bump and then afterwards
it's going to be seeing
that the bump is shaved
down the hip pointer right
iliac crest contusion right
you can see right here
this is very painful this is
very painful I've seen this
in so many of the players
and the football players,
right, a lot of contact
sports, I've seen this in
soccer players, I've seen
this in any time where there's
going to be a lot of contact,
especially in the hip
joint, right, and I've seen
this in referees as well,
right, because sometimes
referees, they've got to
keep their eye on the play,
right, and sometimes they
don't realize how fast the
play is coming right at
them, right, so the play is
coming right at them, and
they're like, oh no, what
are we going to do, right,
and they're going to get hit
in the hip, it's going to
hurt. They're going to go
down. And when we cover the
football game, we're not
just covering for the
athletes. We're covering for
the coaches, the trainers,
the referees, and anybody
else involved with the game.
So the primary etiology is a
direct load to the iliac crest.
Most commonly, the
patient present with
bruising, or we
could say ecchymosis.
Imaging might be needed if
you think that it's faster,
but usually the first
thing I'm going to do, I'm
going to tell them to put
an ice pack on it later on
that night, maybe take some
anti-inflammatory, and then
we'll check it out the next
day to see what the range
of motion, active and
passive, is with the injury.
So here we have a football
player, right? So his number
one goal right here is to
get the ball, right? He's
not really thinking about
how his body is going to
land, and now he's going
to land, and he's going to
create a direct contact with
the ground with his hip.
We're going to talk
about hip dislocation,
right? I mentioned hip
dislocation before.
Most commonly is going
to be the posterior hip
dislocation. Most commonly
is going to be the posterior
hip dislocation, right? So
the hip is very, very stable
joint, right? It's a
little different than the
shoulder, right? When you
talk about the shoulder, you
learned in the last lecture,
right? The shoulder is
very, very flexible, right?
But you're going to lose a
lot of stability, right?
The thing about the hip is
that you have a lot of
stability, right? but you're
going to lose a lot of you
have a lot of stability
you're going to lose a lot
of flexibility right and
that's kind of how we need
it with the shoulder right
you got to be able to put
your hand over your head you
got to be able to drive
turn your hand all the way
in internal rotation
external rotation right so
posterior hip you're not
supposed to see too often right
especially in a young
healthy person but we
will talk about there
are times you will see it
basically you need a high
energy trauma we're going
to talk on the next slide
exactly what high energy we're
talking about um dashboard
injury right dashboard
injury right so you think
about a dashboard being inside
of a car right and now you
think about somebody going
100 miles an hour in that
car and now they go into
a tree right the tree is not
going to move and the car
is going to be severely
damaged right the dashboard
is going to push all the way
up into the hip it's going
to push at the knee and
right through the femur and
it's going to knock that
femoral head out of place.
Physical jams, you're going
to have leg shortening,
and that's because the
hip is going to, once
the femoral head comes
out, it's going to go
superior, right, it's going
to go superior into the
iliac fossa. So it's going
to go up, you're going
to have flexing, and
you're going to have
internal rotation, and you
may have some adduction.
And here we talk about the
backboard injury, right,
so you can picture that
there's a tree over here,
right, maybe he, somebody,
an animal jumped in front
of the car, he went, and he
swerved over to the right,
and he went into a tree,
and now the dashboard is
going to push that femur,
right here, you have the
femoral head, and it's
going to push it right into
the iliac fossa, right,
and that's going to be a
significant injury, and that's
going to be very painful.
So, usually, this is a
high-energy trauma, right,
I do have an event that I
covered pro wrestling uh
where there was a um a
hip dislocation right so
if you want to see that
video i'm not about to show
youtube videos on on
these on these lectures
because they're recorded
but if you want me to send
you the link to the video
i'm happy to and basically
what the guy what the
um what the pro wrestler
did he was going to pick
up the other one other pro
wrestler and he was going
to throw him down and
and you can picture
this is the head,
this is his arm, he's
going to take the other guy
or the other pro wrestler
and he's going to slam his
back into his hip and he's
going to break his back.
He's going to break his
back and that is going to be
the finishing move and
then it's going to work out
the way that they planned
and they practiced and I was
there, it was on youtube
and i can show you how we
kind of immobilize it right
we don't want to do too much
movement we don't want to
damage it we don't want
to make anything worse we want
to avoid any complications
right so it doesn't happen
too often in a sports
medicine setting but it
does happen right another
example is i believe this is
1991 right if you don't know
the team right by this
i'm going to tell you it's
the bangles cincinnati
bangles right and this uh this
man right here he He goes
by the name of Bo Jackson.
Bo Jackson was
probably going to
be one of the
greatest athletes.
Everybody knows LeBron
James. Even if you
don't watch basketball,
everybody knows the
name, like LeBron
James, Michael Jordan.
Well, Bo Jackson would
have been one of those
athletes. He was a
football player, played
for the Raiders, and he
was a baseball player.
He played for, I believe,
Kansas City Royals.
So he played professional
baseball and football.
So here he did a very,
very benign tackle.
So, right, so, and by
the way, because of
this play, they came out
with the curse of the
Bengals, right, where
the Bengals never won
another playoff game
until more recently.
But anyway, going back to
the injury, so this guy
right here, he's going to
grab his right leg, and Bo
Jackson's left leg is going
to keep going forward, right,
and then he's going to
have his leg straightened
up, and all that body weight
is going to go forward.
and now all that weight is
going to go forward and now
that's going to drive that
femur head out of place.
So what was different about
this case compared to the
pro wrestling case was
the pro wrestling case the
hip was completely out,
right? The hip was dislocated.
Here Bill Jackson was
able to walk off the field
so you can't walk off
the field if your hip
is dislocated, right? So
he thinks that, he said
he told the trainer that
he felt the hip come
out and then it came
right back in, right? And
something like that, that
might be a subluxation,
right? Subluxation
where the femur kind of,
the femoral head kind of
calmed down, hangs along the
rim, and then it goes right
back into place where it
should be, right? So he
might have felt that pop out
and then went right back
in, right? And that little
bit of movement, right, pretty
much damaged his football
career, right? Because he
ended up getting a vascular
necrosis, what we talked
about before, right?
Which is destruction of the
bone cells, right? The bone
cell dies because it's not
getting the blood supply.
And then he got
significant injuries
and arthritis that
developed later on.
We've seen it. Football
fans, if you guys
know Tua, we know him
more with Miami with
a concussion. He had
a dislocated hip.
This is just another example
of the injuries occurring.
Then we talk about anterior
hip dislocation. Anterior
hips are less common than
posterior. So posterior is
more common, left is hip,
right, and these are going
to be more physical gym,
again, limited range of
motion, right, so it's a little
bit different, it's going
to have external rotation,
flexion, and abduction,
right, um, the way that
I like to think about
this is if you guys
are thinking about if
you guys are up on a
hill, and, not a great
hill, but if you guys
are skiing down a hill,
right, and I'm, usually they
tell you to go like this
right make the skis like
this I guess right but then
all of a sudden one of the
skis opened up like this
right so you're going like
this and then now you're
going like that the skis open
up and now you have a lock
right here right so as
you're going downhill very
fast right the skis is going
to hit off that lock and
now you're going to have a
forced external rotation and
you're going to have that
hip that's going to go
straight forward right so
you're going to have a forced
external rotation, you're
going to have an abduction,
right, and that hip is
going to go forward,
right, and it's going
to dislocate the femoral
head anteriorly, right,
so we have a picture of
an anterior and a
posterior hip deflocation,
and I mentioned, see how
high up the femoral head
is once it's out of
place in the posterior,
right, that's why you're going
to have the shortened head,
right, that's why, again,
it's going to be shorter,
again, you're going to
wave out this gyotic nerve,
and it's going to look like
it's internally rotated,
right, where in the
external rotation and
you're going to have the
femoral head it's going to
look like this you're going
to have the external
rotation and the hip is
flex and you're going to
have the femoral head coming
out so it's going to look
like abduction on down
here as well again
posterior hip is more common
alright so hip dislocation
treat it right you
can't just ignore it early
reduction is essential
right close so in my
case I was done in a pro
wrestling event, right? So
what I had to do was I had
to make sure he had good
post-motor sensation,
right? I made sure that we
put him on the backboard,
we stabilized the hip,
got him on the backboard,
and we were able to transfer
him out, right? Then
we talk about closed
reduction and open reduction.
Open basically means
surgically, right, versus
closed where they do it
without surgery, and they
just manipulate the bone
to try to pop it back in.
Complications, we mentioned
avascular necrosis.
We talked about the sciatic
nerve, and one thing
I did not tell you before,
but I think it's very
worth knowing, is that on
anterior dislocation you
also worry about the femoral
artery and the nerve.
And then we worry about
osteoarthritis. We worry about
complications that come
from the hip dislocations.
Hip fracture, not a good
thing, especially in anybody,
right? So a hip fracture,
right? Young patient,
it takes a lot of trauma,
right? It takes a lot of
trauma, it takes a lot
of energy to really break
the hip, right? Unless you
have an underlying disease,
right? Older patient,
right? You may not need a
lot of energy, right? Sometimes
you can have an elderly
person that might be a
history of osteoporosis.
The bones are
weak, and they just
fall from a standing position.
So we're going to talk
about different types of
hip fractures. This is not
something I want you to
memorize, but if this is
something that's really
interesting to you that
you might be heading in a
career in orthopedics,
right, so I just want to kind
of just show it to you
all just so you have it,
right, a lot of the stuff
we already talked about,
right, so we talked about
the capsule, right, the
capsule that goes over
the femoral head and the
femoral neck, right, so
this is a capsule, and then
intracapsular injuries are
usually not a good thing,
very, very bad, right, because
you have all the vascular
complication that goes
along with it, right, that's
destroyed the retinacular
arteries that ring the bell.
I said that in like slide
number four or five before,
right? That comes
off the circumflex
medial lateral, right?
But most like more,
mostly the medial
circumflex artery. Medial,
medial circumflex
artery, right? I'm
not going to write it
out, but you get it.
Interchrotenteric ends,
right? So once we start
going down here, then it
becomes extracapsular, right?
Now we have extracapsular,
right? Now we have
less incidence of
avaculonecrosis, and that's
a good thing because that
happened because we have
an abundant blood supply.
How do we treat it? So
you want to protect from
additional damage. Number
one thing at first, do no
more further harm. You're
going to minimize any
discomfort. You're going to
restore the hip function.
You're going to allow rapid
mobilization, and you're
going to want to try to
avoid avaculonecrosis.
Non-op, you always want to
try to fix station. It's
usually what's But there's
other ways to do it,
depending on the patient,
depending on the injury,
depending on how bad the
injury is, and depending
on the experience of whoever
is on call for ortho.
So whether you
put in a couple of
pins, you put in a
couple of screws.
Bigger bones usually
require the screws
to keep it more in
place, but then they
require another procedure
to take them out.
Hemianthroplasty,
basically just replacing
the femoral head. And
then our intramedullary
nail, you might see
at some point, maybe
at some point in the
near future. We're going
to talk a little bit
more in a little bit.
So, again, do not memorize
this. This is not, this
stuff is not going to be
tested. It's just interesting.
This might maybe make some
people interested
in orthopedics.
And we will go on to the
femur shaft fracture. Right,
femur, shaft fracture,
not a good thing, right,
we want to make sure we
get these people treated,
it takes a lot of force,
right, the reason why it's
not good is because you
have a lot of blood loss,
you have a lot of blood
loss, and you're going to
get something called, you
can get something called
compartment syndrome, right,
if it ends up putting a
lot of pressure on the
inside of the, inside of
the leg. We're going to talk
more about compartment
syndrome in a little bit.
But I mentioned before, and
I circled intramedullary
nail, because I think this
is worth knowing. This is
important to know, because
what this nail does,
intramedullary, it goes in,
and basically it's going to
preserve the anatomy of the
fracture site. It's going to
preserve the anatomy, and
it's going to help to limit
the damage of the soft tissue
that's around the bone.
it's going to preserve
the blood supply,
right, and it's going
to allow better healing
to occur, right, so
if you get a fema
fracture, this is just
one of the more common
procedure that they might
do, right, and basically
they're going to, again,
they're going to take a
metal rod, and they're
going to insert it into the
medullary, right, into a
medullary, they're going to
put it into the medullary
cavity of the bone, right,
to provide good support
for the fracture's bone,
right? Some resources
will say this is the gold
standard for any kind of
femur shaft fracture, but then
it depends on the patient
too, on whether they can
even tolerate surgery or
what the complications are if
they don't go for surgery
versus if they do, right?
We're going to move on
to degenerative diseases
of the hip, right? So
So, basically, this is
osteoarthritis. These
are the arthritic changes
that we see more commonly
in the elderly people.
We see this a lot
in the hip, in
the knee, in the
hand, in the spine.
And basically, what's
happening is that the caudalus,
the christening, begins
to break down. So the
christening of breaking
down, and now you're going to
have bone on bone. Bone on
bone is not good. It creates
pain. And now you're going
to get pain, discomfort.
You might get some
osteophytes. right, fancy word,
osteophytes, which is
basically bone development,
bone spurs that
affects the joint.
You're going to have
deficit. You might
have difficulty walking,
sitting, standing.
Usually these types of
people have pain more
towards the end of the
day, more after all the
activities are done for
the day. How to retreat
it, right, this word
right here, ring the bell.
Activity modification,
if they're overweight,
if they're obese,
right, maybe talk
about some weight
loss, physical therapy,
NSAIDs, anti
-inflammatory, right,
Motrin, Advil, Aleve,
Naproxen, Melasticam,
right, there's so many
different variants.
Just make sure you
don't overdo it, make
sure you don't have
any kidney function,
make sure you're
taking the NSAIDs with
food, right, because
it may upset stomach.
Pain management, right,
again, that might
be, you might want to
add some Tylenol to it,
joint injections, and
surgery, potentially,
right. Surgery would
be like a replacement.
Physical therapy is really
going to strengthen the
muscles around it, so here
we have physical therapy.
You really want
to strengthen up
the muscles that
surround the joint.
So here's a great example, bone
on bone, not good, no bueno.
So this is somebody that
might be having significant
pain versus somebody
that might have a normal
space between the femoral
head and the acetabulum.
Joint injection,
right, so I'm not going
to test you too much
on joint injection,
but just know that
there's other injections
you can do for the
patient with arthritis,
whether you give them a
steroid, preparation, but
this might just be a
temporary relief of pain.
A new researcher out there
is saying that it actually
could potentially accelerate
the progression of the
arthritis, right, by breaking
down in the cartilage
even, even sooner than it
normally would, right, and
then you have visceral
supplementation, right, this is
where the patient would
say, I got my gel shot, this
is exactly what they're
talking about, they're talking
about the hyaluronic acid,
right, they're talking
about hyaluronic acids,
and this is more like the
lubricant that you normally
have within the knee itself.
so um total hip replacement
right and a total hip
replacement right it might
also be called like total
hip orthopathy right the
damaged bone and the cartilage
is removed right the damaged
bone and the cartilage
is removed and it's
replaced with a prosthetic
component right the damaged
femoral head is removed and
it's replaced with a metal
stem and it's placed in
hollow center of the femur,
right? So it's placed in
the hollow center of the
femur, right? And then you're
also going to have a
replacement of the acetabulum.
And you're going to
have a nice, smoother
movement when the patient
is walking. And you can
also do it for the
knee, right? So here we
see a thrittic knee,
right? This is a thrittic.
See how you tend to
see bone on bone. You
don't get that over here.
This is normal space.
So again, knee replacement.
But usually if we can get
away with doing physical
therapy, strengthening up
the muscles around it, if
the patient can feel better,
that might be all they
need as far as treatment.
But when it gets really
bad and now the pain is
unbearable, then surgery, my
author might decide to go
in and do a replacement.
We're going to talk about
the knee. So we're going
to talk about the
knee, anatomy, patellar
fractures, instability,
dislocation, collateral
ligament, meniscus, cruciate
ligament injury, bursitis
of the knee, vagus
cysts, so a lot of stuff,
but I know it's dense,
but I will tell you
what's important as
well, but also know that
a lot of this stuff is
one of the more common
injuries that we will see
and we will encounter.
So we have the medial
collateral ligament,
also known as the
MCL. And we have the
LCL, we have the
ACL, we have the PCL.
These are all ligaments that
keep the knee joint stable.
So when you have
a varus, so when
you have a varus
forced to the knee,
basically you're going
to be stressing out the
lateral collateral
ligament. And when you have
a valgus forced to the
knee, you're going to be
stressing out the medial
collateral ligament.
So something like this,
right, and let's say,
let's pretend this is a
knee, and this person's
looking at you, and
you see how this is more
of a varus, right, so
that's going to be
putting a lot of stress on
the inside of the, you
have the varus, right,
so let's say this
is the other knee.
right so now when you
have a various force right
you're going to be
putting a lot of stress
on the lateral collateral
ligament right because
you can you can see
how the knee coming in
right it's going to stress
out the lateral side
um and this guy right you
have one on the medial
one on lateral right
basically they're the shock
absorber, and they provide
stability within the knee.
Why do I even have this
picture of myself? This
is my knee, this is my
fingers. So basically, I
take my middle finger,
I put it on top of my
index finger, and the
reason why I do this is
because I want you all to
know that if you have the
ACL, it's going to go
from lateral to medial,
and the PCL is going to
go from a medial to, um,
medial to lateral,
right? So it's a lot, I
don't even know what the
mnemonic is that they use
to memorize that, but if
you're taking an exam, you
want a quick way to figure
out if the ACL is going
lateral to medial, or the
medial to lateral, do
this quick technique, and
you're going to figure out
that real fast that, um,
ACL is going to go
lateral to, um, medial.
Uh, patellar fracture,
right? Patellar fracture,
again takes a lot of force
you're going to have direct
impact falling directly
on a knee receiving a soft
low to the knee right so
this could be in that car
accident that we talked
about before where you hit
the dashboard uh you could
have a sudden eccentric
right lengthening of the
muscles while your contraction
of the quads right and
that can pull apart the
patella uh symptom inability
to straighten the knee
right um you see the
fracture right there lots of
connection between the
quadriceps and the patellar
ligament. Your treatment
is going to be immobilizing
the knee and an extension
cast, extension cast with
full weight bearing, or you
might need some surgery,
and get an open
reduxion, open reduxion,
internal fixation,
external fixation,
and patelectomy,
basically taking
out the patella if it's severe.
Complication, very,
very bad, propyliteal
artery rupture, and that
usually comes more when
you have posterior
directed force that needs
to, that you might see
in a knee dislocation.
Patellar instability,
right, the most common
patellar dislocation,
right, are going to be the
lateral patellar
dislocation, right. So the
reason why we have a
lateral patellar dislocation
is because A, the MPFL,
the medial patellar
femoral ligament, which
is going to be right here,
is usually what drives
the patella this way,
right. And then you have the
quadriceps right over here,
So right up here, the
lateralis and all the other
quadriceps is going to
pull the patella this way.
So when you tear that
MPFL, medial patella
femoral ligament,
the patella is going
to say, I am going
to the lateral side.
If you have weakness
on the vastus
medialis, which is
the muscle over here,
when you have weakness
to the vastus medialis,
again, the vastus
lateralis is going to pull
the patella to the side.
You might have somebody
that has ligamentous
laxity, right, like EDS,
ill-adonline syndrome, or maybe
they have other instability.
You're going to end up
with a patella dislocation.
How do you treat it? You
want to put the patella
back in place. This
is something you can
do on the field. I've
done this many times on
the field, inside the
ring, inside the cage.
Very, very quick, very easy
thing to do most of the time.
And basically, the patella kind
of just wants to go into place.
So if you all know
Patrick Mahomes, I'm sure
you all know him. He
was in the Super Bowl
three times in a row for
the last three years.
Basically, he had a
patella dislocation
on the field. This is
not his knee. This is
just another knee,
but you should see the
patella dislocated
to the lateral side.
But anyways, as
you extend the leg,
you could glide
the patella back
medially into place
where it wants to go.
Collateral ligament
injury. Right now, we're
talking about the
medial collateral
ligament and the lateral
collateral ligament.
So the medial collateral
ligament is when you have
a high energy force to the
lateral side. So here you
have a lateral force that's
going to go this way,
and it's going to create an
opening and a tear in the MCL.
So MCL commonly
occur with a medial
meniscus because the
fibers are connections.
So when you have an
injury right there on that
medial side, you're going
to tear the MCL, potentially
the medial meniscus as
well. You're going to
have pain, swelling on
the medial side, and the
patient's going to point
to the medial side when
you say to them, can you
point to the pain, right?
They're going to point
to the medial side. We're
going to talk about
athlete's distraction test in
our DPR lecture, right?
I'll see you all there.
In our DPR lecture with
laxity, on valgus, right?
So valgus is when you pull
the leg, the lower leg,
to the outside, laterally.
And that's going to
create a gapping on the
medial collateral ligament.
Lateral collateral
ligament really
injured in isolation,
and it's going to
be just the opposite,
medial force,
medial side force. So
here you have the force on
the medial side. It's
going to create a big
gapping on the lateral
side. It could potentially
increase the laxity and
potentially get a chair.
Meniscus, you could have
traumatic versus degenerative.
Traumatic, think about
the athletes. They rapidly
twist their knee from a
direct contact. so says
when they're being tackled,
versus degenerative,
somebody's a little older,
right, what happens?
We get older, we all get
older, and our joint becomes
dehydrated, degenerate,
the meniscus degenerates,
and sometimes it could
be a simple motion like
we just get out of
this, get out of sitting
down, and we move and return
to the other side, and
that little bit of a twisting
motion can result in a chair.
Medial meniscus is more
common than the lateral
meniscus. The exception is
when you have an acute ACL.
Then that's where the lateral
chairs are more common.
Symptoms, you're
going to feel stiff.
You're going to feel
like you're locking.
You can ask the patient,
do you feel like your
knee is locking in place
when you're walking?
They'll be like, Doc,
that's funny you say
that. It actually does.
It's locked in place.
Popping noise when the injury
first happens. We're going
talk about mcmurray aptly
compression chest joint
line tenderness as well right
these are your examination
skills uh examination
technique we're going to talk
about later on um in our dpr
lab and the location of the
injury will affect the
healing right because in the
peripheral meaning on the
outside um that's where you're
going to get the best healing
potential because that's
where you get the most blood
supply more blood supply
more healing potential less
blood supply like on the
inner two-thirds of the
meniscus right less blood
supply is going to have the
least potential for healing.
We'll talk about
the ACL, right?
Everybody knows somebody
that might have torn the
ACL, right? Very, very
common. I've seen it so
many times, covering
football, a lot of events.
Female athlete, two to eight
times more likely, right?
The numbers fluctuate
depending on the paper that
you're reading, right?
Basically, there's a lot of
theories behind it. One of
them is the increased cue
angle, right? Meaning that
coming from the wider hip,
right? So the wider hip so
instead of the hip being
like this right you might
have the q angle coming over
here so you're going to
have a wider q angle and
what that's going to do is
going to create a valgus
that's a greater it's going
to create a greater valgus
in knee loading uh causes uh
you can hyper extend severe
force dresses anteriorly
with the knee semi-flex
right um you can also have
a non-contact right this
is more common non-contact
more common right stopping
suddenly right, and direct
blow, poor landing from a
jump, often causing an ACL
rupture. Right, it's often,
again, often a non-contact
injury. We're going to
talk about lachments,
we're going to talk about
anterior drawer later on, and
especially in our DPR lab.
Treatment in low-demand
patients, right, we might
just do physical therapy
and lifestyle modification,
right. If this is a
professional football player,
chances are very high they're
to go for um a surgery
reconstruction to stabilize
the uh the knee joint
uh so we we remember just
a few years ago right about
three uh three to four years
ago in 2022 we were watching
a football game and Odell
Beckham right playing
on the turf field again turf
field higher incidence for
um for ACL chair because
you have a stronger friction
doesn't allow that movement
And what he does here, he
turns, he catches the ball,
and then he kind of moves,
and he pivots himself to
his left, and his foot kind
of plants, right? So now
his foot is going to come
outside, and when he goes to
land, he's going to have a
twisting motion with the
planted foot on the ground.
He felt a pop, a
significant injury.
He was pretty much
out for the game.
O'Donohue triad, right?
Definitely worth
knowing, right?
I think even first aid
will tell you to know this,
right? So that means it's
something worth knowing.
Terrible, unhappy triad,
right? So usually it's the
ACL, MCL, and medial meniscus,
right? So this is all
ACL, again ACL, right?
Remember I mentioned before,
ACL goes lateral to medial,
right? ACL, medial, meniscus,
and MCL, But, it's worth
knowing that it's more
common for the lateral
meniscus to be torn in the ACL.
You're going to get this from
a valgus force to the knee.
So the valgus
force to the knee.
So basically the force is
going to come this way.
And you can kind of see
that now you're going to get
a significant compression
on the lateral meniscus.
A significant compression
And that's why you're going
to have that torn lateral
meniscus injury. But
you're also going to have
significant injury over here
with the MCL and the ACL.
Again, compression
of the lateral
meniscus between
the lateral femoral
condyle and the
lateral tibial plateau.
PCL causes contact
injury usually.
You can get an MVA dashboard
injury. right so basically
the tibia is going to
move posterior against the
femur and you're going
to have a hyperextension
injury right symptom pain
swelling difficulty walking
and stability now you're
going to have a posterior
drawer test right posterior
drawer test right we're
going to talk about that in
dpr lab and actually to rule
out any kind of bone
fracture we talked about
potentially tendon or ligament
when they get torn they
pull a piece of the uh of
the bone with it so you want
to make sure there's no
associated bone fracture.
Surgery only needed when
you have multiple injuries
have occurred. A lot of
people do very well with
just physical therapy
if it's an isolated PCL.
So we talk about the
mechanism, non-contact
mechanism, usually less
common, but they're
out there. So in the
injury, usually it's going
to be a direct blow
to the anterior tibia,
right? So here's a direct
low to the anterior tibia,
right? Because somebody's
running and they just land on
their knee and now their
foot is plantar flexed. What
they should have done, right?
Sometimes you think about
like the person running the
second base in a baseball
game, right? And they don't
know if they're going to
slide or if they're going
to stand up and they just
land up landing on their
knees, right? Or somebody that
jumped into a pool and they
think it's nine feet deep,
but it turned out that the
pool was like maybe nine
inches deep right they do a
cannonball and now they have
that significant force that
goes up right um with the
especially with the plantar
flex right it's going to
create a lot of force uh
posterior tibial um translation
right that could tear the
pcl right but if the foot
is dorsiflex like over
here it's not going to have
that significant effect
because a lot of that force is
going to be transmitted onto
the patella and it's going
to go to all the way into
the distal femur and so it's
not going to really tear
so this is not really going
to tear the PCL this is going
to tear the PCL and because
you're creating that anterior
motion going up right
tear the PCL and let me talk
about the contact injury
right you get a hyperextension
right versus us hyper
hyperextension
versus a hyperflexion
right versus a
again anterior to
posterior, tibial,
um, translation, um,
ACL and PCL, right? So
MRIs, I'm not going to test
you on any, um, MRIs, but
it's always good to know
imaging on, and especially,
um, athletes want to see
their own imaging, right?
So if you can pull this up
for them, you can kind of
point out the ACL and the,
uh, the PCL, right? So
basically the ACL is going
to be this, uh, this over
here, right? This ligament
right there. So when you
don't have that ACL, right,
you can imagine that
when you do the anterior
draw test and you're going
this way, you can imagine
that there's nothing stopping
it from going anterior,
right? So that's why you're
going to have a positive
anterior draw test, right?
When we talk about the
PCL, right, we talk about
this ligament over here,
right? When we talk about
the PCL, if it's not
there, you can only imagine
that when you do a posterior
draw test, you can
imagine that the tibia is
going to go without any
end force, end resistance,
the tibia is going
to go posteriorly.
We're going to
talk a little bit
about bursitis,
we'll move along,
bursa, pre-patellar bursa
is most common, basically
inflammation at the pre
-patellar area. So here
we have the pre-patellar
versus super-patellar versus
infra-patellar, so there's
super mean above, info
mean below, and then the
patient's hearing, right?
So this happened because
of repetitive trauma,
right? Housemaid knee,
housemaid knee, right?
Somebody that's always on
pressure, putting pressure
on their knees, right?
Kneeling, wrestling, right?
You're going to get pre
-patella bursitis, painful, um,
basically it's active pain
with active range of motion,
right? So when a
patient during the rain
diversion, it's
going to be painful,
right,
and rest, ice,
anti-inflammatory.
Uh, then you have the
enterine bursitis. This is
worth knowing, first aid
says it's worth knowing.
Basically, there are
three major tendin that
are attached to this
one bursa right here,
right, and the way that
I remember that when
I was in med school
is I remember Sargent.
Sargent, sartorius, gracilis,
and semi-tendinosus,
right, so answering
bursitis can be painful,
sometimes you'll see
somebody get an injection
in the area, right,
you're going to get a
sharp pain, they're
going to point to it more
commonly in the obesity
and overused athletes.
Bakersis, right, the underlying
gastroc and the
semi-tendinosus,
you're going to develop
fluid collection
in the papillineal
bursa. The patient's
going to say, Doc, it
hurts behind my knee.
I feel like there's a lot
of fluid behind the knee.
Generally, they could
be asymptomatic,
but they're going
to say, you know
what, maybe I have
pain behind my knee.
Pain with prolonged standing.
Rupture can cause acute severe
pain that may mimic DVT.
DVT is a fancy way to
say deep vein thrombosis.
And like anything else, if you
have one extremity swelling
and they're saying that they
have pain in the back of
the leg, you always have
to make sure you rule out a
DVT. And that's not something
you ever want to miss
in a primary care setting
or in the hospital setting.
So you rule out a DVT.
Nobody's ever going to
force you for ordering a
ultrasound for somebody
that has lower extremity
swelling because you
want to, again, make
sure you rule out a DVT.
Lower leg pathology. A
few more slides, we're
going to talk about
compartment syndrome,
tibial fractures, and
venous thromboembolism.
So, compartment syndrome.
So, basically, you're going
to have severe trauma.
Severe trauma,
we talked about the femur
fracture before, but usually
it's going to be more common
in the lower extremity.
Obviously, lower
extremity, it could be
upper extremity, but
I meant lower leg.
more common in the lower
leg. You're going to
get swelling and bleeding
within a compartment.
Basically, all the compartments
are lined by a fascia.
That fascia does not like
to be stressed, so it's
not stressable. So when
you have a lot of swelling
and bleeding, it's going to
cause increased pressure.
Now you have a lot of pressure
within the compartment,
it's going to stop the
blood flow from reaching
the nerve and the muscle
cells. The anterior
compartment is going to be
the most commonly effective.
And so it can happen
from a fracture, from
hematoma, bruised
muscle, crest injury,
cast or tight band-aids.
So when you have, when
you wrap somebody and
you wrap it for too hard
and for too long, you
got to make sure you keep
checking and reestablishing
and reassessing.
You get reestablished
blood flow
after block circulation,
reperfusion.
So these are all causes
of compartment syndrome.
Basically, you have increased
pain with a passive stress,
right, parathesia
early on, and then it
might be numbness,
then you get paralysis.
The way you diagnose
it is through
compartment pressure testing.
So you've got to test
how much pressure is in
the compartment, and this
is a surgical emergency.
A surgical emergency
in all compartment,
you get increased pressure,
can lead to tissue death.
And that's what, again,
we want to avoid issue
death. So what are we going
to do? We're going to send
them to the operating
room and we're going to do
something called a fasciotomy.
And this is done to
relieve the pressure,
especially if it's over 30.
So if it's over 30, if
it's over 30, fasciotomy.
Again, the author will
decide on when and how quick
they'll get them into the
operating room. But usually
they'll do it as soon as
they can because it's a
significant deal and you
want to avoid tissue death.
Here we have our fasciotomy.
So low leg compartment,
right, so we talk about
the anterior, deep posterior,
lateral compartment,
and the superficial
compartment. This is
all worth knowing,
definitely important stuff to
know because depending
on what compartment, so
again the anterior
compartment is most common.
So the anterior compartment
is the leg is the
compartment that's most common
for compartment syndrome,
right? It does contain
the extensors muscles,
and also, I'm going to
show you on this slide, it
also has the tibialic
anterior, right? The tibialic
anterior allows dorsiflexion
of the ankle, right?
And then it also has a
bunch of muscles as well as
nerve supply, right? And
I'm going to show again,
this has the deep peroneal
nerve, right, basically
the patient's going to
have pain on the anterior,
right, then you're going
to have the lateral,
we're going to have
the superficial
peroneal nerve, right,
you're going to get
numbness possibly on
the dorsum of the foot,
right, lateral dorsum
of the foot, and then
pain on the lateral
leg, right, and then the
superior and the deep,
right, you're going
to get pain on the
posterior leg, right,
these are both innervated
by the tibial nerve.
So tibial nerve, tibial
nerve, very important
to know, and this is
mostly the plantar
flexors of the
first. So what's the
plantar flexors? The
soleus, the gastrocs.
Again, if pressure
is there, it's going
to create pain when
you are moving. More
specifically, we're
going to talk on the
next slide, why the
action causes the pain.
So anterior, we talked
about basically, this is
anterior compartment has
the muscles that allows
you to do it to flex your
ankle. So why are you
getting pain when your
plantar flexing your ankle?
And the reason is, is
that when you plantar
flex your ankle, you're
stressing out the muscle.
So you're stressing out
the muscle, you're making
it bigger, you're
making it bigger in a
compartment that doesn't
want it to be bigger, right?
So when you plan to
flex, you're making the
muscle bigger, and it's
going to create more pain.
Where if you go just the
opposite, you go into
dorsiflexion, then you're
going to contract the muscle,
you're going to make it
shorter, you're going to
make it smaller, and it's
going to be less painful.
Again, deep peroneal nerve,
lateral, superficial,
peroneal nerve, and then the
posterior, you're going to
have the tibial nerve. Again,
definitely worth knowing.
Chronic exertional, this
is somebody that exercises
and then they feel the
pain, right, so they feel
like they're very stiff, the
fascia does not allow for
the increased blood flow
that the muscles require,
right, it's going to be
achy, crampy, squeezing,
pain, reproducible, cessation
usually of the exercise
usually stops the pain,
right, you might get
parathesia, numbness, foot
drop, right, this is all because
of pressure building up
within the compartment,
right, so again,
know the compartment
pressure, you're
going to want to
find out, and
possibly, potentially,
depending on how
severe it is, right,
potentially needing
a fasciotomy,
right. So fasciotomy,
right, you might see it over
and over again, right, in
the near future, right,
fasciotomy, and as well
as in the far future.
Lower leg tibial fracture,
right, tibial fracture,
high velocity impacts
to the tibia, A lot of
pain, inability to bear
weight, you can't walk,
it's difficult to walk
with a tibial fracture,
x-ray, cast scan,
you really got to
depend on the type
and the severity,
and depending on
whether they're
a surgical candidate or not.
So I mentioned intramedullary
implant before,
and I bring it up again,
this is intramedullary
implant versus fixation.
All right, so we're talking
about Alex Smith, Alex
Smith, Comeback Player of
the Year, back in the day.
He suffered a significant
tibial fracture.
He ended up going for
17 surgeries, that's a
lot, 17 surgeries,
because he was having all
the complications that
developed. He developed
sepsis, a life-threatening
complication from
infection, right, and
he had to wear brains to
combat his drop foot
that he was developing.
Not to gross you all out,
but here we have Kevin
Ware in Louisville. So
he's a basketball player, a
healthy basketball player.
He went up, he did a jump,
normal shot, nothing
significant, nothing abnormal.
And this was all caught
on live TV where the tibia
is coming out. So I can tell
you, I'm not a radiologist,
but I can tell you 100%
that this is a fracture.
And this is an open fracture.
And this is somebody that
needed to get it fixed,
like ASAP, right, like now.
So he went straight to
the hospital, and he ended
up going for surgery
to stabilize the tibia
and to prevent any
potential for complications,
right, like infection.
Because you have an opening
now, a significant opening
into the skin. right,
you want to make sure
you prevent infections.
DVT, I mentioned deep vein
thrombosis, right,
very, very bad.
It is bad, but you want
to make sure you pick it
up. It's not something that
you want to just not even
think about. This is
something that could be on
your differential diagnosis
if somebody is having
pain in the back of the
leg or they have swelling,
especially unilateral
swelling in the uh in the calf
or behind the knee right so
basically you get a venous
thrombus uh that forms
in the vein right whether
it's the femoral or the
popliteal which is most common
right especially if they
have a high risk right so if
they have any stasis of
blood flow right whether
they're on a flight for
nine hours or they're um or
they're post operation and
now they're laying in bed. You
have endothelial damage
versus a hypercoagulable
state whether it's acquired
or whether it's hereditary.
A lot of different
medications can also make
you more hypercoagulable.
It could be
inherited, it could
be malignancy, it can
definitely do hypercoagulable
state pregnancy.
So if people are high
risk, you want to make sure
that you keep in the back
of your mind DVC because
why? Because DVC can
embolized to the lung, and now
it can cause a P, pulmonary
embolism, and that can
also go to the brain or in
the systemic circulation.
DVT, upper leg, so
basically it's going to be
unilateral leg pain. So
anytime somebody comes
in with unilateral leg
pain, like I mentioned
before, or unilateral
swelling, unilateral edema,
right, you gotta make,
nobody's ever going
to force you for
ordering a ultrasound,
right, and it's being negative,
right, because this is
what you had to do, right,
you want to make sure you
order the ultrasound with
Doppler flow, right, you gotta
make sure the veins are
compressing, right, you're
looking for a compression
of the vein, right, you have
non-compressibility of the
vein, right, now you know
something's wrong, right,
if it's not compressing, so
you're going to order an
ultrasound of the lower
extremities, right, nobody's
going to force if you order 10
normal ultrasound of the
lower leg. If anything, right,
you're just looking out for
the patient, making sure
that if your DVT comes to
mind, you're ruling it out.
How do you treat it?
You're going to treat
it with blood thinner,
right? You're going
to treat it with
heparin or low-molecular
weight heparin, right?
And problastic, right,
early fracture
stabilization, mobilization,
right? So every
patient that's going
to the hospital,
they're laying in bed,
pumps anything that can
really get the blood flowing.
For an ankle now we're
going to talk real
quick about low and
high ankle sprain Ottawa
ankle rules and
Achilles tendon rupture.
So we have the medial
ankle and we have
the lateral ankle so
basically the deltoid
ligament is the main
role is to resist
inversion and so that's
going to be on a medial side
right that's going to resist
inversion of the ankle
and then you're going to have
the lateral ligament right
most of the injuries we
have is due is due to the
lateral ligament the main
role is to resist inversion
we're going to talk about
grade one partial chair of
the ligament that has no
mechanical stability right
there's a lot of overlap between
all three i'm not testing
you on the grade of the
ligament brain right because
just know that one is the
least harmful or the least
and uh grade three the
complete chair of the ligament
that had moderate to severe
functional impairment.
And again, a lot of overlap,
a lot of the different
resources might be a
little bit different.
Inversion injuries,
right? This is what
happened when the
foot rolled inside,
inward, right? And now
you're just stressing
out the ligament on the
outside of the ankle.
Sometimes the patient
will say, Doc, I heard
a pop. They're going
to have some swelling,
ecumosis, bruising,
pain, weight bearing.
We're going to talk about
the anterior jaw test
in our DPR lab, so make
sure you guys are in
DPR lab of the ankle,
talus, tilt test, and x-ray
depending on Ottawa
rule. Ottawa rule, we are
going to talk about that
in a few more slides.
Rest, eye,
compression, elevation.
The most common ligament
in a low ankle injury is
going to be the anterior
talofibular ligament, ATFL.
ATF, or which one first?
Anterior talofibular. right,
just make sure you don't
get the confused with the
anterior tibial fibular,
right, basically that's
the higher ankle sprain,
but it's anterior tallow,
right, remember tallow,
right, you know, questions
like to trick you up,
right, so don't get tricked
up with this, anterior
tallow fibular ligament
is the most vulnerable,
right, low ankle sprain,
now you have the eversion,
right, a little different,
eversion, now this is
when your foot rolls outward,
and now you're putting a
lot of stress on them on
the medial ligament right
more specifically the
deltoid ligament now you're
gonna have a lot of pain
swelling with possible ecumosis
and then again Ottawa
rule right figure out if
you need to get an x-ray
or not rest eye compression
elevation right the deltoid
ligament can be affected
keep an eye on it recovery
can take twice as long
especially if the deltoid
ligament is being affected
high ankle sprain high high
ankle sprain, right, so
this is where you have a
sprain involving the distal,
tibial, I mentioned ATF
before, talafibular, this is
tibial fibular, right, so
don't get those mixed up,
right, people do,
right, if you do, it's
okay, we learn from
it, but tibial fibular,
tibial fibular syndesmosis,
right, this is the tibia,
this is the fibular,
in between you have the
syndesmosis, right, and
this is where the injuries
occur, or you can also
call it the anterior
inferior tibial fibular
ligament, AITFL, right?
That's basically more of
the high ankle sprain,
right? So I'm going to show
you some more pictures.
I know we're a little
bit over on time, but
I think the pictures
definitely help out, and they
help me out when I'm
learning these injuries.
So the mechanism is
going to be dorsiflexion,
that's forced dorsiflexion,
and external rotation.
Pain at the anterior,
distant dysmosis.
Swallowing may be
minor or distant,
right? And the squeeze
test, right, we're going
to learn that in DPR
lab, right, so make sure
you guys are in DPR lab,
make sure you're all in
DPR lab. So basically,
with that squeeze test,
you're going to take the
tibia and the fibula and
just picture yourself
squeezing them together.
And if they have significant
pain with compression, right,
or even if they have
a little pain, right,
they're going to, it's
significant, they're going
to probably have a high ankle
sprain, right. The other
test is the external
rotation test, right, and
that's basically you're going
to take the tibia, you're
going to stabilize it,
and you're going to take
the foot and ankle, and
you're going to bring it
externally rotated, right?
Again, that's going to put
more compressant on the on
the syndesmosis, and that's
going to be significant
for a high ankle sprint,
right? So here, I want to
make sure I talk about the
pictures. Pictures
definitely mean a lot, and we
have our friend that we
mentioned earlier with the
patellar dislocation, right?
So I guess when you're a
quarterback and you're on
a great team, right, even
on the best team, right,
you're get tackled you're
going to get hit you're going
to take a lot of it your
body's going to take a lot
of ***** but what i want
to point out here is that
i think the best view is
that over here he has that
foot in dorsiflexion and
you can see as he's going
down right that foot and
ankle is going into it's
going into um external
rotation right so that's
going into external rotation
while his foot is pointing
up right here we have it
again right so this knee
is pushing down over here,
so now he has a dorsiflexus,
right, along with the
external rotation, and that
is going to be significant
for potentially causing
a high ankle sprain, and
that's in dysmosis between
the tibia and the fibula.
Again, I know we're over, but
I want to show you the videos.
Well, I can't show
you videos, obviously,
because we're being
recorded, but I have the
video link if you want
to look on YouTube,
right? Again, we have another
injury usually from the
outside, and from the
outside it's going to force a
dorsiflexion, and you can
see how he, his knee coming
down over here, and all of a
sudden he goes into external
rotation, right? So again,
you have a valgus load,
right? So valgus, your force
is going from the outside
to the inside, ankle,
eversion, and dorsiflexion.
So we have LeBron James
that also suffered a very
similar injury and
again it's a significant
injury because it's also
hard to manage as well.
I could play out
the injury as well.
So a very cool term that
I will show you, I am just
putting my pointer back
onto the pen, is a mason
root fracture. So I bring
this up because it's, at least
in a sports medicine board,
very, very, very, very
common, and you're
going to look incredibly
intelligent, right? When you
have a patient that comes in
with a high ankle sprain
and the attending is talking
about ordering x-rays
of the ankle, right, you
may say, well, how about
we check the ankle of the x
-ray of the knee or on your
physical exam, right? You
do a physical exam on the
ankle, on the syndesmosis,
you do the squeeze test,
the external rotation
test, and now you say, you
know what, let me just feel
your fibular head, right,
and they'll be like, why
are you feeling the fibular
head, and now you're going
to say, because the
force that comes from the
deltoid ligament goes all
the way up to syndesmosis,
and it goes up to the fibular
head, and it can create
a fracture, right, so
again, makes a new fracture,
right,
um,
Ottawa anchor rule, we
talked about this before,
you can know the mnemonic,
or just memorize that you're
going to get point tenderness
at the fifth metatarsal
and the navicular and
inability to bear weight
before step and that's for
the foot and for the ankle
right you're gonna have
tenderness along the posterior
edge of both the lateral
and the medial malleolus
right for me that's a lot
easier than remembering fine
Malbec right if you want
to know this we put this in
here for you right but if
you don't need it right
there's a thousand other
mnemonic you're gonna have to
remember um so in Ottawa
yeah you You might as well
just memorize fifth metatarsal
navicular and unable to
bear four steps, wait for
four steps, or you're going
to have lateral medial
malleoli and tenderness along
the posterior edge of the
lateral medial malleoli.
So again, base of the fifth
metatarsal and navicular,
right? That's for the
foot rule, and then for
the anchor rule, posterior
edge of the medial malleoli,
medial malleoli, medial
view, lateral view,
lateral malleoli, posterior
edge, right? Again, this is
going to be whether you
determine whether you need
to get an x-ray, right?
And this can rule out
potentially needing to get
an x-ray on everybody because
now you have some kind
of guideline to help you,
right?
Last injury we're going
to talk about, artillery
tendon rupture, right?
Attility tendon rupture
usually more predominantly
is going to happen in a
male in their fourth
decade. Very, very painful.
And it's going to happen
at about six centimeters
that are above the
calcaneus insertion because
that's an area that's
hypovascular. It doesn't
get the best blood
supply. It usually happens
on a push-off injury
during running or hard
lateral movement. The
patient might feel a pop,
and they might localize
pain to the ankle pain,
posterior ankle.
Examination, you're going
to have a palpable gap.
It's going to be obvious
deformity potentially
if it's completely
torn. you're going to
have lots of resistance
to passive dorsiflexion,
right? So you're
going to have lots of
resistance to passive
dorsiflexion, right?
Because there's
nothing, the Achilles
tendon is completely ruptured.
And the other thing is
you're also going to have
a Thompson test, right?
So again, that's coming up
in our DPR lab and DPR
lecture in a little bit.
Non-surgical treatment, right?
Versus surgery, right? A
lot of research is going
both ways. Now it's more
non-surgical. You can get
them in early functional
rehab, right? But depending
on the, again, depending
on the patient,
depending on the severity
of the injury, right? So,
again, Achilles Handon
-Rubster, who, one of the
greatest basketball players,
we all know, number 24,
Kobe Bryant, right? So
Kobe Bryant, when he went
down, right, this was a
very hard step onto the
ground, and he said he
felt like somebody kicked
him in the back of his
leg, right? And that's
exactly how people will
describe it. He felt like
somebody kicked him in
the back of his ankle,
but there was nobody
there. He just
felt a pop as he
pushed off that ankle.
And one of the cool
things is he still got
up and he was able to
make his free throw.
So a couple of questions.
We can go over it if you
want together. If not,
basically a 65-year
-old female, history of
AFib, PVD, peripheral
vascular disease, and
coronary artery disease,
come to the office,
emergency room 12 hours
after pain in the right
foot. On physical exam,
the right lower leg and
the foot are pale and
cold with absent pulsions.
Right, so right lower leg
and the foot are pale, cold,
absent pulsions. However,
the left side has no abnormal
finding. All right, so it's
only on the right side.
Acute limb eczemia is
diagnosed and emergency surgery
is performed to restore
blood flow through the leg,
right? So now you have
reperfusion, while in recovery,
complaints of intense burning
pain along the lateral
leg and ankle, right? P,
so is the normal appearing
leg, right? So what is
the most likely diagnosis?
And to those in the front,
you guys said C, and
the answer is C, acute
compartment syndrome,
right? So in the interest
of time, I do apologize. I
know I'm a few minutes late.
So we will have the same
patient. What compartment
is being affected? Again,
let's all go back to that
shot that I showed you,
right? So this is going to
be the lateral compartment.
And what action will lead
to increased pain? Again,
it's the action that's
going to go opposite to
the function of the
muscle, right? So in that
case, It's going to be
inversion and dorsiflexion.
And the nerves, as we
mentioned before, are
going to be the
superficial fibular nerves.
So a summary, we always
like to summarize.
Anatomy, dislocation,
hip, femur fractures,
IM nail, intra-meduline
nail, I mentioned
that. I'm not going
to ask you about
any of the surgical,
other surgical, um,
for fractures, right,
obviously for other
surgeries like fasciotomy
is fair game, um, but
I am now, right, um,
basically in a femur
fracture while we put it
in there, we throw it in
a few of the pictures,
a few of the slides,
uh, knee, patellar
fractures, instability,
dislocation, MCL, a lot
of ligaments, right,
um, the ligaments and, um,
the MPFL, everybody always
forget about the MPFL,
lower leg, compartment
syndrome, tibial fractures,
DVC, foot, ankle, sprained
inversion versus eversion.
Here's a good summary slide.
If you can, please leave
feedback. If you have any
questions, comments, concerns,
or you have a great idea,
I want to make the lecture
good, I always like pictures,
and I think when I
incorporate the pictures into
the lecture, to kind of help
with the learning process.
So definitely the feedback.
I do, again, I
apologize. I know I'm a
few minutes late, but
I hope I definitely
made this lecture
worthwhile for you all.
So this is actually
at AEW. I was with
the team doc, also
a DO. The doctor
for AEW, how cool
is that, is a DO.
He's based out of
Atlanta, Georgia.
So when they come up to
New York, you need a new
york state license so a
few times i was able to go
and hang out with them at
the show at the new york
state license doc covering
covering the event um
i know it's a lot of
information very dense there
but i can promise you that
it's going to be uh okay
again if you have any
questions please let me know
have a great evening
morning afternoon thank you